we are hearing more and more las vegas
gaming companies on how the cobit
pandemic
has really affected an impact in revenue
today red rock resorts the parent
company of station casinos releasing
the last quarter earnings and that
revenue was down 36 percent from 2019.
christian casares joining us live from
our newsroom and christian
some of the properties still close any
discussion on the future of them
well brian i can tell you that that was
definitely addressed the palms will most
likely remain closed until its tourism
customer base returns
as well as texas station fiesta rancho
and fiesta henderson
will also remain closed a timeline
relying on the vaccination process now
the company
with 20 properties right here in las
vegas they say they have no intentions
of selling any unused land
or properties another topic they touched
on was the opening of their buffets
they said they don't see that happening
in the near future because of the
pandemic
their loyal 65 and over crowd has been
shy of coming back
but they are optimistic on their return
once the vaccine distributions
are complete since we reopened in june
i think we have surprisingly seen a nice
increase
in the younger demographic especially in
sign ups in our rewards program to
create these direct marketing
relationships
with a younger profile
the company also announced enhancing
their focus on family initiative which
centers on enhancing long-term health
safety and financial security for their
team members
and family now over the past year they
have also
opened up two medical centers for their
team members
and their families live in the newsroom
christian casadas 8 news now